okay uh we have a transcript from a
bizarre interview that Donald Trump gave
The Wall Street Journal which reads much
like a Saturday Night Live script and in
distress trip we learned that Jared
Kushner referred to I'm sorry that
Donald Trump referred to Jared Kushner
as a good boy the good boy who is going
to be solely responsible for solving the
israeli-palestinian conflict Donald
Trump also said that the leader of the
Boy Scouts told
Trump that his Jamboree speech was the
greatest speech ever made - then a
statement since denied by the Boy Scouts
and I want to go through some of the
questions because when you put when we
have a transcript of Trump's words it
really illuminates how clueless this guy
is to a point that we should all be
hovering scared in our basements over
here was a really good question about
what is Trump considered to be his
accomplishment so far and one of the
journalists said what are you most proud
of in the first six months great
question how does Trump see this Trump
says a lot of things oh we're going off
the rails already
I think I'm proud of the Supreme Court
choice and that's not just a nomination
that's getting him through I'm very
proud of opening up regulations one of
the reasons you see optimism is because
people can actually use their land they
can farm their land I've had tremendous
and tremendous look I had 45,000 people
there yesterday it's the biggest crowd
they've ever had and they were they were
going wild yesterday in West Virginia
but people can actually use their land
and they can build so let me interpret
for you Trump asked here what are you
most proud of in the first six months
and he answered by saying his Supreme
Court pick which he just picked a name
off of a list that was given to him by
right-wing think-tank not much of an
accomplishment and when trying to list
other accomplishments he once again said
that there was a really big crowd at a
speech that he gave and I forgot that
farming and building were outlawed under
the Obama administration oh yeah you
couldn't farm you couldn't build it was
crazy not none of it happened under
Obama next question what are the
disappointments so far for you and here
it goes completely off the rails
this Baker asks what about your
disappointments any disappointments in
the first six months and there's a
pretty damn long list right Trump says
well I'd have to let you know I'd have
to see where we are
this let's see maybe it doesn't work but
I think it's going to and you know it is
it would have been easier to start with
taxes but this is better if it works
okay if it works this is better and the
Wall Street Journal follows up and says
more general generally and Trump says
but I think you know depending so if you
ask me that question in a month or
really at the end of the year because we
hope to get this we hope to get taxes
and then infrastructure and then I'm
going to do a very big we're doing very
big trade deals and we're looking
forward to that
but we want to do ideally this first you
know a lot of people said you should
have started with taxes or you should
have started with infrastructure well
infrastructure I'll actually have
bipartisan support and I can use
infrastructure to carry other things
along so I don't want to waste it at the
beginning if that makes sense what are
you talking about well you gotta give
him a break on this one because there's
been so many disappointments and
failures how could we expect that he
would actually list all of them yeah
then they discuss tax reform and god
bless him at the Wall Street Journal
they tried to get Trump to explain what
he's trying to achieve via tax reform
couldn't get an answer okay
Baker asking what are the what are the
main goals and sit down folks strap in
Trump says I want to achieve growth with
the highest tax nation in the world
essentially false you know of the size
but we're the highest tax ination in the
world we have nobody knows what the
number is also untrue we know what
taxation is in the United States Trump
goes on I mean it used to be when we
talked about when we talk during the
debate 2.5 trillion dollars right when
the most elegant person right I call him
mr. elegant I mean that was a great
debate we did such a great job but at
that time I was talking two point five
trillion dollars I guess is five
trillion dollars now whatever it is it's
a lot more so we have anywhere from four
to five trillion or even more trillions
of dollars sitting offshore we want to
get that back know one at a very
reasonable cost and that cost is going
to be 10% and right now it's so high
that no no one you would never do it on
a business basis but no to
bureaucratically is impossible did you
know that I have friends that try and
get their money back they say they have
to go through years of writing out forms
and this and that to bring money back
into the country
we're going to make that one like a half
page document it's going to be very easy
to bring back your money back in and
it's going to be taxed at 10% which is a
rate that it's within reason and that's
one of the things we want to do that'll
be an easy one that's one that you know
it's when you talk about a country
that's broken or a system that's broken
there's something the five trillion
let's call it that the Democrats and the
Republicans agree should come back in
it's been out there for years nobody
ever did anything about it I mean Obama
the how is this the President of the
United States how is that an answer to
that how is it even an answer to the
question that's exactly right
then they move on to the corporate tax
rate and Trump can't help himself here
he starts talking about how great his
relationships are with other world
leaders this is just amazing asked about
the tax rate and he talks about how
great the relationships are that he has
built okay Wall Street Journal asks what
do you think is a reasonable corporate
rate we've heard 20 percent but and
Trump drums at Trump jumps in he goes
well you know we're going for 15 we're
going to see and we'll see but you know
I don't want to say anything about
negotiation I mean we're asking for 15
percent and we think we're going to grow
tremendously so I deal with foreign
countries and despite what you may read
I have unbelievable relationships with
all of the foreign leaders they like me
I like them you know it's amazing so
I'll call like major major countries and
I'll be dealing with the prime minister
or the president and I'll say how are
you doing oh don't know don't know not
well mr. president not well I said well
what's the problem Oh GDP 9% not well
and I'm saying to myself here we are at
like 1% dying and they're at 9% and
they're unhappy so you know these are
like countries you know fairly large
like 300 million people you know a lot
of people say they say well but the
United States is large and then you call
places like Malaysia Indonesia and you
say you know how many people do you have
and it's amazing how many people they
have so China is going to be at 7% or 8%
and they have a billion five right so we
should do really well but in order to do
that you know it's tax reform but it's a
big tax cut but it's simplification its
reform and it's a big big tax cut 15
Trump seemed to suggest
that he calls the leaders of other
nations and asks them what's the
population of your country
yeah that's bachelor number one that
seems to be a regular if you believe
Trump and why would anyone believe Trump
but let's assume he's telling the truth
he calls leaders up and he says tell me
the population of your country that's
part of the conversation our president
is having with other world leaders also
sounds like he's bragging about speaking
to all these world leaders I mean I
expect you to have that access as the
president of the United States he's
still bragging about the fact that he
talks to world leaders like it's some
shocking thing for the American
president to be doing and I think this
is the last one right Pat Trump has no
idea what health care reform is and he
was asked well what exactly did you do
to try to get it passed and it turns out
it was very little Trump is asked what
have you been doing mr. president sort
of behind the scenes Trump says a lot a
lot okay Baker follows up I mean what do
you think the crucial conversation has
been many conversations I just had one
with a certain senator that was very
convincing to that senator so I've done
a lot I mean last night last night it
was amazing I was at that you know I was
in West Virginia doing certain things
and making a speech to the boy scouts
and that was some crowd that was an
incredible crowd again asked a question
about a specific policy and he talks
about a crowd that he had he goes on to
say but I've been working hard trying to
get the Senators to go along with it and
I you know I think I you know look just
don't quote me on this unless it
happened but I think we have a pretty
good shot and that votes taking place at
about two o'clock today right
two o'clock Wall Street Journal says a
little bit later yeah exactly a little
bit later Trump says and Wall Street
Journal says all depending on McCain's
plane landing Wall Street Journal goes
on if you get the vote if you get the
vote today to go ahead what will be the
next hurdle that you and Trump interrupt
well then you have to go and decide on
what plan you want which way you're
going to go you want to decide on is it
repeal or replace and report is it
repeal or repeal and replace if it's
repeal and replace which one do you want
to go which form of existing conditions
I mean there's many things but once
you're in there then you can really
negotiate president of the United States
if you were to read a script
for a Saturday Night Live parody of
Trump giving an interview it would
basically be this transcript wouldn't it
yeah it's no wonder that he so rarely
speaks to newspapers off camera because
you know when he's on camera and you can
hear his voice he has a way of speaking
with confidence yeah you know you sound
like an idiot but not like that much of
an idiot you look at the transcript I
mean there's no intelligence there and
this is the President of the United
States if the Wall Street Journal showed
up here right now and you say David in
ten minutes you will be interviewed by
The Wall Street Journal and we're going
to interview you on these issues as if
you were the president I could fake it
better than Trump did in this interview
that that's the degree to which this man
doesn't know anything and it emboldened
some trumpets because it's just a
regular old guy and he'll figure out the
details later which he doesn't and he'll
put the best people around him which he
also doesn't do discuss this with us on
our reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad